[Applause]
welcome welcome welcome ladies and
gentlemen welcome to smod castle i'm
kevin smith you all know what we're here
for tonight uh it's being buschemi
ladies and gentlemen and eve with steve
we're here to celebrate an icon get into
his head and heart find out what made
him tick in some of the biggest movies
that we've all uh loved him in um it's a
benefit ladies and gentlemen uh we're
live streaming here from smod castle in
leonardo new jersey
mere steps from quick stop where we just
finished shooting clerks 3. so this is
the first event that we've been able to
hold in the space since we wrapped up uh
clerks three one person enjoyed that
thank you so much
[Applause]
that is the one person who will be in
the theater when we open thank you
thank you the rest of you will be
watching on [ __ ] netflix or something
um
uh uh it's uh a benefit tonight ladies
and gentlemen it's friday night um
hopefully if you're at home watching uh
your kickback you got yourself a drank
uh a joint um you're feeling charitable
and generous because my god we're
raising money tonight for one of the
greatest causes
on the planet ladies and gentlemen i'm
just going to put this on front street
who doesn't want to [ __ ] a firefighter
um
everyone loves [ __ ] firefighters man
um
they run into buildings for us buildings
are on fire they bring out cats babies
other humans and [ __ ] like that uh
they're some of the best people you'll
ever encounter in this world when it
wouldn't talk to any kid even now in
this day and age when their children
what do they say they want to be fire
fire well they say firemen but fire
fighters is a different age at this
point um tonight we're raising money for
the friends of firefighters uh an
organization that is about to celebrate
its 20th anniversary uh sadly its
anniversary is in the wake of september
11th uh but uh out of uh that horror
came something wonderful and positive um
and something very very necessary and
the good folks at friends of
firefighters have been doing this now
for two decades uh tonight we're raising
money for them so open up your hearts
open up your wallets um we're going to
uh
update you all night long
how much money has come in uh who the
big donators or donors donators are
throughout the evening ernie o'donnell
will jump out here smod castle keeper
himself ernie o'donnell will update us
with the figures the in between each
chapter we got 12 chapters to go down
ladies and gentlemen uh 12 chapters of a
career
sometimes there's just one movie in that
chapter sometimes there's a couple
movies in that chapter uh but all those
chapters are filled with the movies and
tv shows that you've always wanted to
know uh what our guest uh would like to
say something about and he's gonna say
it tonight uh we'll spend a few minutes
on on each chapter then when the
chapter's over we'll get an update on
how much we've made so i'm just warning
you in advance it's gonna be a fun show
it's gonna be the entertaining show but
we are gonna be asking for money all the
time so a free show the only cost is
you're gonna have to hear it again and
again and again
and again it's for a good cause we're
gonna find out about that cause uh from
the mouth of the man himself ladies and
gentlemen uh let's uh not wait
uh any longer without further ado
um the man who brings more honor to smod
castle uh than it possibly deserves um
tony blondetto
comes back to jersey ladies and
gentlemen uh
he ain't mr purple he ain't anything but
mr pink man welcome to our stage the one
the only the legend the icon the great
steve buscemi ladies and gentlemen
[Applause]
have you ever been to leonardo new
jersey
i have never been to leonardo leonardo
new jersey
and um
kevin was nice enough to take the hit
for you know starting late but it's
because it took me two hours to get from
eighth street to the tunnel
that's even before the tunnel
on a friday night i'm shocked yeah i
know i'm like
eight o'clock on a friday night um do we
have to leave at two in the afternoon i
think that's what i'm that's what i
should have done you have so much guilt
over this i was like don't worry about
that
our crowd they're stoners they don't
even know what's on the front and i see
like people outside and i like panicked
and i walk down the block
there was there was a facial i'm sorry i
couldn't face you there was a question
backstage they're like uh steve's here
but he's walking down the block and i
was like maybe he missed the theater and
they were like how could he miss the
theater um but uh we collected him and
he's and he's here and uh we're gonna go
down 12 chapters of his career but
before we do that we just want to first
talk about why we're here the
organization we're raising money for
tonight with being buschemie and eva
steve is uh friends of firefighters this
is very close to your heart
yes it's an organization that was
started by nancy carbone
she's here somewhere i just nance where
are you okay
all right get back there all right come
join us next week
yeah come on up
everyone give it up for nancy carbone
[Applause]
i
you could totally lose the mask you
could take your mask off can i just just
for now just for now
um tell them tell them about friends of
fire enough yeah the back of the room
you're looking at the back of the room
to tell them see that i see the back of
the room and i actually came from the
back of the room so i know where to look
well done
friends of firefighters started right
after 9 11 and i think after
the day of 9 11 everybody was
stunned
and i think
the first thing people wanted to do was
help in some way and a lot of people did
they they helped um i'm that person that
never went home
they probably wanted me to at some point
because i was in a lot of firehouse
kitchens
um just asking what they needed and
initially it was boots
bunting for the firehouses socks
the tangible things that they needed to
get the job done
but as time went on and we got closer
and there was a trust between me and the
firehouses they started to ask for
counseling outside of the fire
department
i'm not a counselor
but i'm a mom so moms get it done there
are moms in the audience right you get
it done people ask you to do something
you get it done right these are first
responders
first responders ask for something
you make it happen and i i didn't know
what the hell i was doing it was my
first curse and it was my old friend
very much
so you get away with saying hell in the
land of the jersey devils it's very very
easy
um
i was honored to be asked in december of
2001 to start a counseling center for
firefighters that was apart from the
fire department so that there would be
confidentiality it wouldn't end up in
their records
and i never expected it to last 20 years
and now it will last past my lifetime
because the job that they do is so
dangerous
and the families are affected so we are
helping firefighters that are active
firefighters that are retired and their
families we have counseling but we also
have other services uh that have
developed over the years to bring in
those that are a little bit gun shy and
don't want to sit down that's okay they
don't have to sit with the counselor
we've got
acupuncture and
financial assistance basically we're
trying to take those worries off of them
because the jobs that they do
bring them from sitting on a couch in a
kitchen
to in the middle of an inferno grabbing
a baby
and if you think about that for a moment
what is your most uh
stressful moment but catching a bus
right i mean
our stresses are so far
removed from what their stressors are
and they don't forget the fires where
they lost people they don't forget the
smells the sounds and 9 11 it all came
together and those who were at 9 11
and survived
a lot of them are getting sick and
cancer is through the roof and so we're
there to help those families but since 9
11 there have been a lot of fatalities
also so firefighters have been killed
doing their jobs
the stress that it puts on the family is
is
i don't even know how to express that
because we talk with the families and uh
it's a dangerous dangerous job so what
we do we made them a home uh we are in
an old firehouse in brooklyn
over 400 firefighters came to rebuild
the old firehouse it was it was really a
shitty place when we got it right it was
uh it was a second curse
a little stronger and let's talk about
that building up to it building up i
don't know what the will be but it will
be strong um the the firehouse was was
just [ __ ] and um it was a metal
fabrication they changed it uh over the
years it's 140 year old building 400
firefighters came to turn it back into a
firehouse to me that validates our work
so what i want to tell you is that
this need
for
not just counseling it's bigger than
that it's a home it's a sanctuary it's a
place for them to go when coveted hit we
were already online so we just
transferred everybody nobody lost one
session
during covet and we helped a lot of
families through that but now that we're
back at the firehouse the needs are even
greater and more firefighters are coming
in the past year we've hired two more
fire of two more councillors i'm sorry
we've had uh almost 50 firefighters come
forward to volunteer and now we're in
the midst of hiring another councillor
so what does that tell everybody that
there's a need right the people are
coming firefighters are coming
and when you call 911 anywhere in the
country you know somebody's coming
and our firefighters in new york city
are there within a minute
and it takes its toll
so
don't they yes they are brave they're
totally brave and strong and they also
walk away from a fatality they also walk
away from a job that went south
and it carries with them for years and
it's not just about 9 11 it's about the
dangers of the job so we've made a home
for them
i want to just give a moment to say you
know steve buscemi
yes he's a celebrity yes he's a
wonderful guy but he was also a
firefighter so he understands he's a new
york city firefighter that understands
what that firefighter takes home with
them and how dangerous the job is
and also
the the 911 related cancers that they're
you know for a lot of these guys and
their families 9 11 has never stopped
you know the cancers showed up after
five years
you know we thought it would be 20 or 25
years five years and uh and we're losing
guys we're losing uh
firefighters and we're
and a lot of them are sick
so this is and this could just be the
tip of the iceberg
so um that adds a whole new level of
stress so
thank you all for being here thank you
is this the hook this is just the hook
it's not the hook before the hook though
before she goes hold on nancy
i always ask uh nance like hey give it
to me in a sentence that i can
like say to the crowd
and you said it backstage so beautifully
and eloquently and you're going to ask
me to repeat something that i have no
[ __ ] come on
it was only a glass of wine for god's
sakes it was a half glass and i actually
gave it to my daughter so i had a little
bit of it
uh you know what it is i i here it was i
think heroes is in it no heroes i know i
don't use the word hero because they use
that for baseball players
and this is
this is different than hero because the
you know these are the people that we
depend upon
they have our backs right everybody here
knows that
what happens when they need help
is it our obligation to help them i
believe it is so i've been in there i
thought it was going to be like a
two-year thing and then they'd say all
right we're sick of you go on they may
still be sick of me but they love
friends of firefighters and i'm not
going away because the need is there
that's not what i said to you but i
don't remember i think it's something
like it might be and correct me if i'm
wrong like uh
the these are the people who rescue us
why can't we help rescue them
and why couldn't you just say that kevin
i you know i was i was gonna let you do
but it was eloquently put it was really
good i will tell you now that i never
remember what i said and people say say
it again for the camera no
i can't but what i can say is that what
i'm talking about is real and and
to get people like like kevin smith and
steve buscemi on board and gary sinise
on board they understand that this is a
need that's real and so i appreciate
everybody coming here
i've never been here before it's pretty
cool yeah nice and
on jersey and [ __ ] she's all new york
and whatnot so she was throwing a lot of
shade but now that you're here it's
pretty nice right now you better say
nice [ __ ] in front of these people
some of them are from new york
fair enough and i do it because i know
it gets under your skin but i think
there's parts of jersey that are
gorgeous the other parts i have to drive
through to get to the good parts so come
on
you can't blame me you just lost a bunch
of donations but please send in that
money yeah really heavens
um give it up for nancy everybody that's
the hook
um folks watching at home
the link is in the youtube description
click on it start donating um before we
even jump into the 12 chapters i figure
like this is the internet the internet's
watching and we want the internet's
money what the internet always wants is
news about comic books and stuff now you
don't have any obvious comic book movies
in your career but i just i read
something online
that i wanted to see if if it was true
or not because
it's a story i haven't seen told
anywhere if it's true and if it is the
internet will go [ __ ] crazy we might
even trend on twitter so even if it's
wrong just [ __ ] lie man like
this is gonna be amazing so i saw
on on uh on the internet that after
batman and robin the warner brothers
movie batman and robin they were
intending to make a movie called batman
unchained
and that the scarecrow was going to be
the villain
and that they were talking to you to
play the villain
is that true
oh i can't lie nah they never talked to
me maybe they thought about me but it
never i don't remember have they ever
come after you for any comic book movies
no
i mean i consider ghost world uh a
comment truly absolutely is a comic book
movie well
my god you saved my ass otherwise the
internet right now he did one you
[ __ ] idiot
um all right man here we go chapter one
we're going down to man's career uh
remember folks the link is in the
youtube uh uh description
uh give thick and fast and hearty we'll
get updates between these chapters uh
before we even get into the acting
career where were we born
i was born in uh brooklyn
yeah
[Applause]
why acting did anyone act in the family
was there any creative influence or were
you the first like the astronaut my
grandfather on my
uh dad's side he he was a
he was a singing waiter in coney island
i never met him but
i used to hear stories that he that he
sang with uh jimmy durante like he was
also
and um
so that was my only oh but wait a minute
my mom's dad
he was a projectionist so
you know does that count yeah
it's a it's a finger in a tailwind movie
theater yeah absolutely i did have uh my
dad's best friend growing up was this
guy named peter miller and we called him
uncle pete not a blood relative
but he was an actor he you know he grew
up in east new york went to the
neighborhood playhouse
became an actor and he was in like these
movies he was in robert altman's first
film the
delinquents he was in blackboard jungle
he played uh i don't know if you
remember the kid that tries to rape the
schoolteacher and gets beat up by glenn
ford that was my uncle pete
um he was in uh crime in the streets
it's like a don siegel early movie and
cassavetes i think it was his first was
his first film he had a little part in
uh rubble without a cause but he was cut
out but he knew nicholas ray
so he was my other you know but but he
lived in california we lived in brooklyn
right and i remember like one of the
first times talking to him on the phone
i was just so nervous i didn't know what
to say to him and i said uh
uh
do you know the three stooges you know i
thought he lives in hollywood they must
all know each other you know
and uh but that was my main you know
influence as a kid wanting to be an
actor was one don't leave us hanging did
he know the three stooges no no he was
very gracious about it he says well no
no i never met them but uh you know
he probably named somebody else who i
didn't know you know but uh but that was
my first taste but yeah but i just grew
up you know just watching
tv you know anything from the three
stooges to gilligan's island to old
movies like the four o'clock movie and
and they would show some pretty intense
movies you know and then like the bowery
boys like comedies like that and laurel
and hardy and abbott and costello i
loved comedy and that was my dream was
to just
somehow get into you know like being on
a tv show like a sitcom
and uh so for a while i tried stand-up
comedy
because i thought that was the way
you get discovered to be on a sitcom do
you remember any of your material
i'm just going to say no i'm not going
to judge any of that material
um
i didn't have you know what it was i
didn't really have a style like
i used to sit and watch
jerry seinfeld and gilbert godfrey and
you know like all these great people
that came through and all the ones that
i really admired had their own voice
and
myself and a lot of other
comedians who are you know much better
than me but we all were sort of
borrowing from this one influence from
that one and but i i i could never find
my own thing
and so i eventually stopped doing it
because i i just realized that i loved
acting more i needed to act with
somebody and and that's where i feel
like i found my voice was through acting
did you start in high school
acting or no uh only
until my senior year you know i was
pretty much a jock in junior high and
high school i played soccer i mean
hopefully that wasn't an insulting
[ __ ] like double take but when you
say i mean it's one thing to be like i
played sports but like to term yourself
as a jock what did you do i was i played
i did you beat up nerds that's what a
jock is to me no no no no no
i played uh soccer i was on the
wrestling team and i and i did track for
like a few years eventually i gave up
track and i just really didn't just just
concentrate on soccer and track i could
totally see but wrestling wrestling yeah
yeah are you a good grappler i was i was
not bad i was i was i kind of held my
own yeah and i had a secret movie were
you a better wrestler than a comedian
yes
what was your secret move my secret move
for the any wrestlers out there was the
reverse cradle
but you could only do it once because
then they know it's coming and it's easy
to avoid
but if they don't know it's coming you
could you can surprise them and you can
beat really good guys you know because
it's you could either pin them or uh you
know like get like three points ahead
it's a third act of the movie kind of
move right yeah yeah like oh my god he
did it um
all right so
you
you're in new york so it's easy to
audition for
films and tv shows no i had no idea what
you know how to be an actor you know
when i moved into the city i was you
know from long island so born in
brooklyn moved to
long island when i was eight long island
is the new jersey of new york yes yes
there you go
i feel you i feel it i feel all of you
um
so i moved into you know
avenue
in east village in 1978
and uh was taking acting classes and and
uh trying to do stand-up and then
working odd jobs
and um i know i didn't have you know i
didn't know how to audit i didn't know
that was why i thought well at least the
comedy people like comes like there's a
built-in audience right you can get on
at a decent time slot
but uh otherwise i just didn't know what
i was doing and i kind of fell in with
the group in the east village
uh at that time people like rockets
reglair
mark boone jr who i did a lot of
work with
jim jarmisch was around and so people
were making films people were making
music
art and it was just a really like
explosive time
uh it was like you know like paris in
the 20s like that's what the east
village was in the late 70s and 80s
and there i was in the middle of it it
took me a few years to sort of get my
bearings but
i finally started doing some performance
pieces and plays and sketches and uh
and when i was doing that i never really
even thought about getting an agent i
you know we were just worried about like
getting the next show like like we would
get the gig and then we'd have to write
a show and then we'd have to perform
and um
and then from that was how i sort of you
know that's where germa saw me and
people like eric mitchell
um
filmmakers uh eric mitchell like liza
bear and
people like that and um
and then uh i was doing some work at
folk city
they used to have a they used to have a
theater night at folk city this folk
club in the in the village
and a good friend of mine kathy kinney
we were
on the same bill and her friend bill
sherwood came
and because he was looking to cast his
movie
his first and only movie parting glances
and um
it was because he saw me perform
he asked me to audition and that was
like one of the earliest auditions that
i had
and he said to me you know your audition
was terrible
i was really bad confidence building he
said i know he said but if he said if i
hadn't seen you on stage i don't think i
would have
cast you so
it made me realize oh auditioning is
such a different thing from you know
actually performing on stage you really
have to i think i went in and i was kind
of nervous and
tried to play it down and and i just
came across as like but he had seen you
rude he knew you're getting but he saw
me on stage so yeah that leads us into
chapter one because the first movie is
parting glances 1986 uh bill sherwood
directs you play nick um this is the
first big acting gig you've done a few
minor roles prior to that i had done so
eric mitchell had his movie the way it
is elizabeth did a movie called the
force of force of circumstance but they
hadn't even been released oh my god you
know total indie film they made the
flicks and waiting to go they
so parting glances yeah that was that
was a very big deal
um
and uh and this movie for those that
don't know it's uh that takes place in
the gay community has big
age storyline hiv storyline which was
insanely revolutionary in 1986. yeah i
played a character who was a rock
musician who had who had aids and the
main story is about a gay couple living
on the upper west side and one of them
was going to go to
africa to work for the world health
organization and it's just a
relationship film yeah and it's you know
so
and the characters just happened to be
gay it was there was no coming out story
or feeling like i'm hiding being it was
just these characters are gay and this
is their story
and um
and i had a just a wonderful part and um
you know being a low budget film we
would shoot for like two weeks stop he'd
use that footage to show it to people
and then you'd get some money oh get out
of here it's done over a period of like
six or seven months you know in these
like just a two-week period here or
two-week period there yeah
and you mentioned bill this was bill's
shirt bill sherwood he wrote it he
directed it and then he himself died of
aids you know uh only a couple of years
after the film after this film was out
yeah he never got to make another never
got to make another film heartbreaking
what um what do you remember about him
as a director
he well he was very funny you know um he
would get
he'd get so annoyed with me and he'd say
things like uh you know he'd get very
specific on now this line you want to
begin and now on this line i'd like you
to move over there and then when you do
this line so i would do everything he
said and the next take he should say
jesus christ steve show some spontaneity
trying to do what you told me
it was a great lesson it was like okay
you have to do both you know you have to
kind of be able to follow
good direction be very specific but not
lose the life out of it you know bring
something to bring something else to it
that is surprising
what um when did the movie go places
like festivals and stuff like that i
think you know i think it did go to
i can't remember what sundance was
called before the american u.s film
festival was yeah so it went there but
but i didn't go
um and uh
where did it open in manhattan it was at
a theater on the upper west side
i can't now i can't remember the name
but i think it also played in the
village you know uh i think at the
waverly so in two theaters and back then
if you made an independent film if it
punched through
and got halfway decent reviews it played
for months yeah yeah um were you
recognized from that movie like people
started being like hey i saw you in a
movie uh a little bit i mean not you
know there's like not a ton of people
saw it but it was
it was i remember the first like when
the movie was released and there was a
review in the paper in the in the times
and an agent from icm
read the review i'm not even sure if he
saw the movie he read the review and he
calls me up and he said you want to come
in and you know and i'll uh
and i was so nervous about it
that i totally blew like like the day i
was supposed to meet him i kind of blew
him off i like i was out all night and i
just you know i
i was so nervous and anxious and i such
a such a jock move dude
luckily i called him and i apologized
and he saw me again and he took me on
for a little while
um and it didn't work out because i
think i was with a big agency too soon
right but anyway that got the ball
rolling i mean that you know i was able
to then meet casting people and
and then directors and um yeah so
that movie definitely got
got me in the door there it is chapter
one give it up for chapter one folks
[Applause]
we finished chapter uh we find out how
we're doing for our fundraising for the
friends of firefighters and we ask uh uh
because modcastle keeper ernie o'donnell
come out and give us an update ernie
come on out and tell us how much money
we made give it up for ernie ladies and
gentlemen thank you everybody
so as of the show started that's even
before you got into it steve we were at
31 36
donated the top five was lawrence at 400
lb at 250 frank at 200 and sarah m
driver at 200 and jennifer 150. oh hey i
know sarah driver said did you say sarah
driver
yes i did yeah
sarah m driver yes
thank you sarah there it
sarah driver is one of the filmmakers in
the east village you know uh she's uh
partners with jim jamish and um i worked
in his feet and in her early feature
sleepwalk and jim was the
cinematographer on that he shot
sleepless he shot sleepwalk
and
nan golden was the still photographer
which is you know i don't know if you
know nan golden she's a world-renowned
photographer and she was the still
photographer on on that film um this is
like a indie film fan's wet dream like
all these rock star names that you're
throwing out uh those donations are nice
kids but let's jack them up remember
friends of firefighters friends of
firefighters ladies and gentlemen
chapter two
um we're gonna do two movies in in one
bite because they both happened in 1989.
uh
just the aforementioned jim jarmisch
makes mystery train puts you in it in a
scene with joe strummer the
aforementioned rockets red glare yes
um
you knew you knew jim from the village
at that point
we yeah we knew each other from you know
so boone and i would do these shows with
rockets rockets had he was a comedian
and he was in you know a lot of jim's
films but he had this cabaret called
rockets red glares taxi cabaret it was a
midnight show and he bounced around you
know different venues in the east
village but we mostly did it at club 57
which was an amazing
club where a lot of uh great people came
out of that
and um
yeah so jim would just
see us and and uh and we were also you
know proud when when jim's films trained
within paradise sort of like punched
through
and um
you know not that it it was not a
mainstream film in any way but it was
the first taste of us you know like hey
people are like talking about this film
and people are the nyu film school kid
people are seeing it and
um it was just so inspiring i think to
all of us who were you know
who were doing our own work to see that
you know and jim did it in such an
uncompromising way you know
he only makes films that that he wants
to make and
and he's made a career
out of it and uh you know he he still
continues to to inspire me so he does
stranger than paradise he does down by
law and then he does mystery training
yeah
um do you remember shooting the movie
with his shot in memphis takes place in
memphis i assume and i was so excited to
work with joe strummer because i was a
big fan of the clash
and also uh ricky avilas he was the
other
member and i used to see him he was a
comedian i used to see him perform in
washington square park when i first
moved to the city and i would just hang
out in that park
and just watch you know jugglers and
phillip petit used to like put up a rope
in between two trees and just do like an
act
i'm like
jesus this is like
it's all free like free shows in
washington square park and ricky was
like
one of the greats so i was excited to
work with both of them and rockets was
in it
and um
yeah we
we rehearsed it for
i think like two two weeks and that's
the thing about jim it's like he you
know he really values
rehearsal time and then he'll do
sometimes he'll do improvs within the
rehearsals and even brought in elizabeth
bronco who plays my sister in the film
we didn't even have a scene together but
he would just have us improvise as
brother and sister and just see what
that
brought up and it was great for us as
actors we shouted in memphis oh
screaming jay hawkins is in it and
and sankey lee
and uh
i remember doing a scene with uh
screaming jay hawkins you know the three
of us
me joe and rick
we're out all night drinking and we get
into trouble and we try to check into
this hotel and screaming jay hawkins of
i put a spell on you fame
is uh the night clerk along with sank
elite
and uh
i we come in and in the scene i drop a
bottle of liquor in it and it crashes on
the ground
and screaming jay looks at me and his
line was boy you got a curse on you as
sure as the day is long something like
that but instead he went boy you got a
spell on you
and i went
screaming jay hawkins
i was like
i was so happy i think i've arrived
this was like amazing yeah it was great
fun to work on that film same year is
the first time you get to work with
um a director
that nobody's ever heard of martin
scorsese yeah you do uh his segment of
new york stories that had roseanne
arquette in it and nick mcnulty yeah the
artist segment
yes artist life or something yeah
um it's funny i felt like i had worked
with uh
i'm gonna call him marty i mean do it
i feel i worked with marty yeah no i i
had auditioned for uh the last
temptation of christ
for like like three times he kept
bringing me back and you know oh my god
you were going to be like one of the new
york voices in jerusalem yes for like
maybe this apostle or that apostle but
he he really already had the apostles
cast from a few years before he was
going to do the movie with aiden quinn
and he had all the apostles cast the
movie fell through
now he's doing it with willam but now
he's you know i guess maybe he wasn't
sure if they were all available i guess
they were and i couldn't i couldn't get
in there but he remembered me
and then when he did new york stories
there was a section in it that uh where
nick nolte and rosanna arquette go to a
club and they see
a performance artist who's um
interested in rosanna or dating or
something and
and they wanted somebody like eric
bogosian you know somebody who like
really did their own
their own stuff and i think my uh i
think ellen lewis the casting director
said do you have anything that we could
send to him and
and so i yeah it was like part of a
monologue i used to do in one of the
shows that i did with boone
and i just wrote that up and sent it in
and so they used me and my material in
it
and uh it was it was great how strange
like to go to eventually watch
uh a short but a martin scorsese movie
and know that you wrote some of it as
well well my i mean my part of it yeah
yeah that's enough that's credit
um what is he like as a director i mean
you've worked with him many times since
then but i love him because he's so
passionate about what he does
and he really is a renaissance man i
mean of course he knows everything about
film every actor every director but he's
that way about history about art about
music and so it's just so much fun just
talking to him about about anything you
know and especially when we were doing
boardwalk empire you know that's when i
really got to you know sit in a room
with him and talk about prohibition and
gangsters and this one and that one and
then
movie references and he's so generous
like
he'll he'll you know name an actress and
i'm and he sees that i don't know who
that is and then he'll send me like all
these movies of you know like this
he's just amazing yeah um cyborg martin
scorsese question yes and this comes
from josh roush uh our cameraman
uh in the irishman
you have a cameo oh that's right
no no not in the irishman
in um
the wolf of wall street sorry i was
gonna say was i in the irishman
am i really forgetting things i'm doing
wall street how did where what was was
it shot just for the movie we had an
argument not an argument but we were
debating whether we shot off a movie or
something
that people hadn't seen that he just
grabbed
no this was remember the tv show the
equalizer yes you were on it i was on
the equalizer i'm in an episode it's me
and john goodman we're in the same
episode we didn't have any scenes
together
but uh yeah i played like you know a
sleazy clerk in a uh antique shop and
i'm trying to hustle the exterminated
exterminator what's his name equalizer
guy
sorry i'm a little tired um
and yeah and he kind of bends my thumb
back to get information out of me and i
don't know who remembered that i had
that i did this but it may have been
terry winter who wrote the screenplay
because we were all doing boardwalk
empire
so uh terry wrote uh the screenplay for
both of wall street and marty did it and
one of them remembered that i was in
this you know like i that i was in that
show and they found it and they used it
as a clip in the movie i think rob
reiner's character is watching it on tv
so awesome uh that is chapter two kids
give it up for chapter two
earn
ernie
we got an update
the only update you need to know is
somebody just donated a thousand bucks
just dropped it
dropped it like it's hot
that's awesome yeah who is that person
you know no they didn't give us a name
but uh we are over seven thousand
dollars that fast very sweet kids well
done well done
thank you
um okay we go to chapter three
uh this is 1990 1991 but it's the same
directors and it's guys that you know
very well 1990 you do miller's crossing
you play make 1991 you do chet in barton
fink
um
this is your first exposure to the coen
brothers miller's coffin yeah miller's
crossing i auditioned for
and um i just remember even at like that
stage in your career yeah but i really i
mean i hadn't done a lot a lot you know
i mean they i'm i'm not sure if they had
seen me in anything but i but i was
brought in
and i read for the part of mink and the
part of mink is like it's like five
pages long and it's mostly mink talking
you know
so i just figured this guy must be a
fast talker
and um
i had good training at it because i was
you know part of the plays that i used
to do in the east village i worked with
um this playwright director john jezerin
and his stuff was very surreal a lot of
non-sequiturs and very fast pace so you
really had to be on your game and so
this was like oh it's linear and it
makes sense you know like i think i can
memorize this almost but i i um
just talked really fast and the two of
them just were laughing they were just
you know like so the more they laughed i
think the faster i talked
did it
and then
i went away and then they called me back
it was like a month later because they
were auditioning other other people and
they had me do it again
and then ethan afterwards and he was
laughing he goes well you still say it
the fastest
and they hired me and then since then
they just you know what is it like to
work with two directors at once
it didn't well i mean
that's the thing it's like they list it
separate but all i've ever heard is they
co-directed yeah but i think now i mean
now ethan is is taking credit as a
director as well and but it was always
that way they were always together
um and always
you know sort of giving the same
direction from the both of them there
was never like a conflicting thing or
one of them pulling me aside and being
like don't listen to that [ __ ]
and they're so low-key they're so chill
you know that's the thing that is funny
because some of their movies are you
know so crazy but they're not they're
they're just
um and they laugh you know you sometimes
you hear them laughing behind the camera
during a take
and uh it's a little distracting but
it's also it makes you feel good
it just makes me happy to know they
laugh they seem like like guys that make
comedies but are very cerebral about it
like you hear this it's like oh good
they like it
uh what do you remember about doing
barton fake playing chet
well that was great we shot that in l.a
at the wilton theater if anybody knows
that theater we shot it and that was the
hotel yes we shot it well not the hotel
but the hotel lobby the hotel itself i
guess was a set
um and uh
yeah it was just you know just playing
that character and just coming i just
love the entrance you know like coming
up like
shining shoes it was just uh yeah it was
so uh memorable and influential for me
that there was a scene in the clerks
that when we shot the movie clerks uh
years ago plugged for myself um please
my friend vincent pereira
who worked over at the store with me um
at one point the character randall goes
to another video store and he meets the
ideal video store clerk and he was named
chet and he gave the same performance
that he gave but the camera crapped out
that night so he couldn't capture it
then he also helped me come up with the
list tonight vinny and josh were very
helpful in terms of like where to go
with the career and uh so far i think
we've gone to good places all right i'm
gonna jump to chapter four that was
chapter three give it up for chapter
three kids
chapter four stands alone uh reservoir
dogs 1992 you play mr pink man um
who found who do you find quentin and
quentin find you
no it was you know that came through my
agent at the time nancy green uh she uh
sent me the script
i read it i loved it she said do you
want to talk to the director i said
absolutely the writer you know he's
going to direct it
and when i
was you know in my mind it was written
by like an ex-convict you know
you know eddie eddie bunker who actually
ended up playing mr blue in the film is
an ex you know or was an ex-con convict
and that's who i thought i i i'd be
talking to a guy like that you know like
he wrote the movie
straight time and and yeah and so that's
and and then to hear quentin's voice and
this like kind of like hey man how you
doing thanks a lot for reading my script
thanks a bunch i'm like
i think i even asked him could you write
this
yeah yeah man i was like okay
and he had such enthusiasm
and
uh
i just then i just i wanted to do it
even more
and
but i had to audition
they wanted me to uh put myself on tape
back then it was like and you know we
had like these big big fats
cameras you know it wasn't like a phone
where you're like i'm doing a self tape
and i tried to put myself on tape and it
was just awful and i don't even think i
sent it
and i just thought well i guess i'll
have to let this one go
they were casting in la
and harvey keitel was already you know a
part of the movie and he was a producer
too
and he insisted
that they come to new york to see new
york actors i didn't know harvey at all
you know i think he wanted to get some
of his new york friends in there too you
know but because they came to new york
then i was able to uh go on the audition
and actually i was filming in the soup
at the time i know we're going to talk
about that but i was filming in the soup
and seymour casella and i went in and we
auditioned together are you [ __ ] me
yeah and then they called me back you
know and then i went and see more
gazelle audition for reservoir dogs yeah
and then i went back
for like a call back
and in front of me was michael imperioli
and i got nervous i was like [ __ ]
he's here god damn it
and um i auditioned uh you know
didn't hear anything
i was invited to the sundance lab where
they were workshopping um reservoir dogs
before it became a film and for those
that don't know what that is so the idea
is sundance picks some filmmakers uh and
based on scripts and whatnot
bring them up to a sundance uh the lab
not the festival itself and they bring
together like seasoned mentors yeah they
have like directors like
gross bard and they had a lot of you
know and it was and it's and it's great
because it's like being at a festival
with nobody else around it's just you
and these filmmakers and these other
people who are trying to be filmmakers
and so i was invited to do the workshop
but the condition was that i they they
were not going to tell me if i if i had
the part you know like you know you just
have to decide to you know
and i said fine i said at least i'll
i'll get to work with him i mean if i'm
not in the movie at least i'll get to do
this right
and you know we worked together for like
a day and and then we were both in the
in the men's room
and quentin turns to me and he says oh
by the way you got the part mr pink i
was like really
oh
thanks yeah you're so weird
told you got the part while you're
holding a party
[Laughter]
um who knew that quentin was that kind
of bathroom guy you know guy that gives
you the good news right in the shooter
um what do you remember about shooting
the movie well again quentin had us
rehearse for two weeks
uh just the actors like in a room and
just reading it for a while and talking
about it
and then we even like we
did like an improv rehearsal of us
robbing the jewelry store you know like
something we never see in the movie no
it's never it's not in the movie but he
wanted us to feel that to like you know
and uh and it was great because then by
the time we got on set we just kind of
you know like we were like a tight group
you know um i remember especially
hanging out with tim roth a lot uh even
though we didn't have a lot to do in the
in the film but uh it was just great to
like bond with these with these guys and
matson and
chris penn i you know he was
he was funny because
she was not very nice to me during like
rehearsals filming and i thought
what am i doing like what's the how can
we you know and then we were at the
reservoir dogs did end up going to
sundance and he came up to me and he
gave me a big hug and he says hey man
come here i'm sorry i just couldn't like
you doing them you know my character
didn't like your character so i couldn't
like you i'm sorry sorry man and then
then he was my best friend
that's committed performance that's
right i loved him yeah what was it like
going to sunday is that the first time
you've been to sundance or did you go
before
i've been there before i think that was
that was the first time and i was there
with uh in the soup and uh both were
there the same year in the same year
so in the soup won the grand jury prize
yeah
seymour cassell won the first ever
acting award that they that they gave
and uh and reservoir dogs was shut out
it didn't it didn't get anything
so um
yeah it was you know they were friends
right quentin
yeah and um
uh what was i gonna say i lost my train
of thought doesn't matter well we'll
jump to in the soup since we're we're
talking about it so the same year so you
shot in the soup before reservoir dogs
yes all right so 1992 you also have as
you just mentioned in the soup you play
adolf overall this is considered your
first leading role
pretty much yeah yeah um
alexander rockwell uh he had made a you
know a few features before that and this
one was you know i think his most
personal film you know like up to that
point and i felt like i was sort of
playing him i played a young filmmaker
who's you know trying to get his script
made and it's like this this thick
and uh and he's in love with his
neighbor and
uh but then he falls in with this like
kind of gangster con man who says he's
going to produce the film but really
he's just taking a lot of dollfoe on his
robberies and cons and drug deals
um but it's and it's a love story
uh you think it's a love story between
me and my neighbor who was brilliantly
played by jennifer beals but it's
actually a love story between me and
joe
seymour's character because you see how
they how they bond and by the end of the
movie seymour's character really wants
to make a film and then you know he's
really like make your film kid yeah it's
sweet it's beautiful inspiring movie
black and white too right black and
white classy um
we love the black and white we do you
know only the best filmmakers dot dot um
what uh what do you remember about the
reception it wins the grand jury prize
at sundance does that make a difference
in an actor's career it certainly helps
a filmmaker but does it mean anything
for you again i think it you know that
definitely opened doors and what was
weird was that what a great year though
oh my god you're walking up and down the
[ __ ] hill and people are like mr pink
adolfo mr pink like they got you on both
sides
what was weird about sundance you know
in the suit was getting so much love you
know
and
every screening of reservoir dogs the
first screening that we went to the
projector broke down during the mexican
standoff oh i swear to god
and
and i think every screening that i went
to at least it seemed like half the
audience walked out when michael madsen
is doing you know doing yeah yeah it's
just saying oh [ __ ] this movie and then
we'd say we just killed him
the air comes off i'm on my
feet um it's so weird to think that
there was a moment where people like
quentin tarantino was not for me and
walk out of a room you know people were
yeah people were you know kind of like
they said this is the most violent film
ever and i was like it's actually not
very violent i mean that that that's
what there are somebody but you don't
actually you know there the way he shot
it was always kind of artful kind of
like yeah just pans off yeah you know
more horrifying but i think it was it
was just the fact that it was so um
these guys were so ruthless
and real you know that i think that's
what people were sort of reacting to
like and of the two films too in the
soup would be like welcome at sundance
because it's a movie about filmmakers
making films so an audience fave as well
whereas reservoir dogs so weird to think
like i remember when reservoir dogs came
out and it
didn't like light up the box office
right it became a real home video hit
but pulp fiction of course more than
made up for it somebody on facebook my
friend vinnie pointed out he said i saw
a theory on facebook he's like just say
it to steve buscemi i said i'll do that
vinny
uh the theory is there's not theory
somebody noticed on facebook they were
like in reservoir dogs you give all that
[ __ ] about like i don't tip i don't tip
and then in pulp fiction you play a
waiter i play a waiter i thought that
was poetic justice i don't know if
that's what quentin had in mind
you know but um i thought this is great
like i'm playing and not only a waiter
but a buddy holly waiter it's almost
like he's he got away and he's hiding
out like he's forced to wear this bad
wig and glasses and you know
and uh mr pick got away yeah mr pink you
know i like this i like your unified
quentin verse theory man
and you know they had a lot of the um
the people who played you know the
waiters and waitresses were all supposed
to be these
celebrities and they had you know people
who did that for a living like they were
these impersonators impersonators so
here i am as buddy holly
and one of the background people like
she's watching my scene and she's just
like she pulls me aside she goes can i
ask you a question i go sure she goes
why buddy holly
i said
what do you mean she goes well you're
not very good at it
thank you for the advice
i'll try harder
all right that is uh you know what
that's chapter five give it up for
chapter five kids
i'm gonna take us to chapter six before
we check in on the tote board again and
chapter six uh is the adam sandler
chapter in in 1994
you're in airheads with him
in 1995
you're in billy madison with him and it
begins of long-running relationships
yeah adam and i
we just took to each other you know just
during the rehearsals and read-throughs
of airheads was he a fan like was he
reservoir dogs fan yeah yeah and i was a
fan of his from snl so it was you know
and the fact that we were playing
brothers then we wanted to hang out and
try you know and so we would go places
and we would go out we would work out
together we were actually you know
because i was a jock i was uh
you told us stop [ __ ] bragging we
know
no i'm playing this like metal rocker
with tattoos so i wanted my arms to be a
little bit ripped oh [ __ ] so you
actually put some [ __ ] physical work
so we were like working out and you know
do you hear that marvel the man will
work out
and i thought this is great i'm working
out and i did used to work out in high
school and i had stopped for a while but
now i'm like i should do this i'm going
to continue as soon as we wrapped up i
don't think
what is it like does he just call you
out of the blue to be like we're doing
something come play
he said you know when he yeah that's how
it is now and when he did his first film
um
yeah he said i just boosh i need you for
one day
can you come up to toronto and you know
i s okay you know and and uh
and you know he's so funny because
you do the scenes and then he then he'll
just yell stuff out at you like you know
try this line and now and now try that
and yeah um put the lipstick on now you
know just and then just lay back okay
you know
yeah
um has there ever been a moment where
he's like come do something and you're
like i ain't doing that
no there but there but there were at
least two movies where i just wasn't
available you were doing something else
i i just couldn't do it yeah it's sweet
to see you as a regular all the time pop
up man um speaking of regular we'll go
right to chapter seven then uh chapter
seven of course is fargo 1996 uh you
play carl show walter
um
you redefine the wood chipper for
america
uh by the end of the picture um what at
this point in your career you don't have
to audition for the cullen brothers i
assume no because i had already done
three films with them so um they and
they told me about it i remember joel
talking to me about it you know after we
did barton fink
um and i thought that was going to be
their next one but then they did
hudsucker proxy and i i had a little
part in that it was fun but so i had to
wait for it you know and then but it was
so worth the wait when they sent me that
script i was just like oh my god what
was when they when they talked about it
years before
was it
close to what it was and was it called
fargo
i don't know i don't know if he even
said what the name of it was he just
said that i would be this guy you know
this sort of like bumbling kidnapper guy
and and
i was like yes please and uh
and when i read the script it was just
it was just fantastic you know and uh
and it was so much fun to do i mean i
always tell this story i read i read the
script and you know my character is
referred to as funny looking
[Laughter]
so when i i'm talking to both of them on
the phone and i say you know i'm
thinking like so what should i do to
like be funny-looking
should i do something with you like with
my nose or maybe we could you know i'm
you know what about braces or what you
know i'm standing all the my ears could
stick out and i just hear silence
i went or maybe i don't do anything
anyway
um what uh you guys shot in minnesota
yeah the same time we were shooting mall
rats wow and while we were shooting all
rats we kept hearing like oh that fargo
man they're [ __ ] they can't find snow
that's true there was no snow that year
you were having one of the warmest
winters yes we had some snow but we
didn't have it for a lot of like the
road stuff and and we kept having to go
further north we went into north dakota
and we were you know practically in
canada for uh some and they changed and
they created snow you know like when i
go to the airport and i'm you know like
they had to it was a little bit of snow
but they had to like make a whole bed of
snow like out in that parking lot it was
it was insane so and for scenes like
when they're out in the middle of
[ __ ] nowhere at night
well
some of that was shot in a studio when
we were in the car
is that right yeah oh my god like i make
movies and even though i was like yeah
you guys must have been cold then yeah
it wasn't like a studio studio i mean we
were inside indoors yeah
thing and the doors were open so there
was so it was a little bit cold but we
were protected like like we were in
there and it was a controlled thing but
we shot you know i mean but we did shoot
at night like outside and
and uh i loved working with peter
stormarr
we go pancakes house he's you know
he it's so funny because it was a
complete role reversal like i'm like the
chatterbox and he's the guy who just
sits there
yeah pancakes
and then they say cut and then he comes
alive and he starts telling me a story
for like 10 minutes and i can't get like
a word in and then it's like all right
rolling action and then it reverses and
you know
and then one night after rap
we went to a diner
and i drove the wrong way down a one-way
street and i got pulled over by a by a
by a cop
and i'm driving and peter's here and you
know we had just
done the scene where he like shoots the
cop
oh my god this is like really weird
and
of course nothing happened you know
but and uh
the officer you know she asked for my
you know license and registration you
know like just like in the movie
and then i kind of talked my way out of
a ticket i don't know how i did i said
hey i'm from you know i i really was
going to call true walter i didn't try
and give her 50 but i'm like yeah i'm
from new york i don't really don't know
you know it's a rental car and i'm just
we could settle it right here in
brainerd
she let me go
and i always wondered you know and i'm
sure like everybody in that area saw
fargo you know like when it came out
and i'm wondering like did she have like
a weird deja vu
she's like i dodged a [ __ ] bullet
[Laughter]
those guys are [ __ ] nuts
um give it up for chapter seven kids
[Applause]
let us uh bring out uh mr ernie
o'donnell and find out uh how much money
the good folks have been doning since
we've been doing stuff uh earn what do
we got
we have just got over nine thousand
dollars
nice very nice topper
top earners sasha berman had a thousand
will wilkins at 500. well wilkins we
know him that's very nice uh
200 for jlg
and damien dusk 150. very very nice
give it up for those thank you very much
keep it going baby
uh what about you know we keep asking
about the internet what about here in
the room folks not to shame anybody into
anything but anybody uh
have anything they want to donate we can
make that happen for you
cash
yeah we take all donations
say again 100 bucks ernie will come out
and take it grab that guy's hundred
bucks before he changes his mind
how you doing
did i bring my wallet
oh no you said a hundo
actually i'll take everything you got
oh my god this is so sweet for the
firefighters wow your friends there
[Applause]
i got it buddy thank you very much 200
bucks right there
how sweet thank you thank you
i see a hand go up over there
10 000
dollars
from lilu multi-properties lulu
multi-props is donating ten thousand
dollars yes sir oh my god
that's how we do it at the castle baby
are you sure you can do that didn't you
just have a baby we did yeah uh she's
actually with nana right now um we're
gonna we're gonna pick her up afterwards
and tell her that she's going to go
without for a few months yeah
my grandfather was a firefighter for
many years um so if he was with us he
would be very happy to hear it that's
[ __ ] beautiful thank you so much give
it up for lil moji props ten thousand
dollars
[Applause]
lest we forget my man's two hundred
dollars give it up for that as well
we got somebody back there wayne's
pointing another hand ernie's bringing
the mic back there
kids that's so [ __ ] generous that's
crazy thank you
she's quietly saying 150. 150 man that's
beautiful
[Applause]
beautiful uh all right i got another
hold on hold on another one oh [ __ ] let
me grab some of these are flowing yeah
leonardo is part of uh middletown
township and middletown township has the
guinness records for the largest world's
largest volunteer fire department that
is absolutely true right now folks if
you're watching at home we are in
leonardo new jersey right near the quick
stop where we've shot clerks and whatnot
leonardo is a borough within middletown
township and middletown this is a
factoid that was shared with me not too
long ago uh i forget i think it was the
mayor of middletown was telling me uh
middletown holds the guinness book world
record
for largest volunteer fire department
middletown township still has a
volunteer fire department it's like they
took a picture it's like a thousand
volunteers i don't know if it's that
venue but it's pretty big it's pretty
yeah it's massive and you know
i grew up in a volunteer fire department
community so like that to me was always
the way and then i found out like some
people get paid for it and stuff like
that that was amazing to me and the navy
sink um firehouse is number one
and it is the first firehouse to ever
have a fireman's fare is that right the
navy sync is the first one to do
fireman's fare yes look at you you're
all sorts of information well done give
it up
all right let's die we good let's dive
back into it shall we and that was a
nice donation of a hundred and i think
we got a couple more here oh
hit him up hit him up thank you for that
hundred bucks more importantly thank you
for all that middletown information that
juicy middletown is there any way
possible the man just handed me a what
you got there
a visa
he
what's the limit sir
what was that what'd you want to
he wants to do 500 on the visa 500 done
and done we can take care of that
make that work
and make that work after very generous
thank you for that my friend i think i
see someone over here
my man
hundred dollars
right there
incredibly sweet
you already overpaid for tickets to be
here tonight and adding more money to it
means a lot thank you kevin i would just
like to thank you for putting tim and i
as extras and clerks three oh you guys
are the one i just saw you today in the
cut you're in the movie oh thank you so
much i watched you walk right past as
dante gets laughed at while he's on the
phone see what happens when you make
movies we make money brother that's true
yes they promised that and it's coming
true there we go thank you um all right
we good
nancy's like shut the [ __ ] up and
collect the money kev
another hundred kevin another 100
it's actually my birthday weekend
37 37 men happy birthday thank you thank
you happy
birthday i got one more hold on one more
here we go
i cut it off if you got the if you want
to give we're taken
taking it hard
what was that thousand
you can tell
one thousand one thousand dollars man
give it up for my man
we'll get that after the show we'll take
the thousand after the show say that
we'll get the thousand after the show
thousand bucks after the show he doesn't
have a thousand
[Laughter]
uh beautiful all right anybody i mean no
shame if we we can move on
oh i said there's another hand right
behind erin oh
my father who was the volunteer farms
kevin i'm donating a hundred
in honor of my father frederick j hill
who was a volunteer fireman in atlantic
islands and passed away 20 years ago at
the age of 61. give it up for a man
timmy hill giving for his dad
[Applause]
beautiful beautiful soul god everybody
knows a firefighter don't they so nice
um okay we good
we are let's dive into it well done give
it up for ernie running around the
microphone collecting money and [ __ ]
[Applause]
uh chapter eight the aforementioned
comic book movie ghost world terry's why
golf directs you play seymour uh really
bittersweet wonderful
uh part um and and very human yeah um
and complex as [ __ ] like there's nothing
simple about it based on uh the dan
comic
and um
yeah thora burke scarlett johansson
you know were just amazing together
terry zweigoff who had done the
documentary
on crumb which was you know phenomenal
uh so that yeah that was a really that
was a really fun
shoot and i just loved watching terry
because he's sort of obsessive about
what's in the frame you know or like
what the background people are doing and
thor and i would be like doing a scene
and he'd like walk towards us
he'd walk past us and he'd go up to the
background you've got to be sadder just
walk just be sadder as you walk by come
on guys they got to be sadder everybody
like recruiting people yeah i'm you know
the background he's you know and then he
walks past us and we're like uh okay
nothing i guess we're good
yeah but he just he's watching
everything you know so if one thing is
off
it just yeah he he just has to correct
it what do you remember about the girls
both of the at this point in their crew
the women at this point in their career
thor birch had already done american
beauty coming off american beauty and i
knew scarlett's work but not many people
did i mean um
uh so i and she was 17 when we when we
did that film
and but i but but uh she had done some
independent films that i had seen before
so i was excited to work with both of
them it was just yeah it was uh
it was nice what is uh do you get
recognized you know when a
one of those marvel kids does a movie
they recognize the world over did you do
you get recognized i love it
when women come up to me and say that
they love ghost world like they saw it
when they were teenager and
uh and something about those characters
you know
thor's character and scarlet that just
spoke to them and i'm getting the
residual love from it because i think
that's how they felt when when they were
in high school so um how how did you uh
did you
it's based on a comic book so did you
look at the books at all yeah
yeah i love dan's work i think she's
just so brilliant he's so funny
um and it was a studio film and
um and i was not you know on the list of
the studio and but terry really wanted
me and he fought for me
yeah yeah he really you know like
wouldn't do it without me so
it's because of him that i you know like
he fought to get me in in that film
great director right there yeah that's
chapter eight give it up chapter eight
[Applause]
chapter nine takes us to uh two movies
that came out in 1998 i can't imagine
they were shot around the same time but
we'll find out couldn't be more
different from one another
big lebowski
[Applause]
and
armageddon one uh
with uh both films made with auteur
filmmakers the coen brothers on one side
michael bay
on the other let's start with uh
we'll do we'll do donny in the big
lebowski did you work a lot it seemed
like when i watched that movie i'm like
he worked maybe a week tops no i was no
we i was around you know for the not the
whole shoot but donnie is in a lot of
scenes where you you don't really know
he's there
like he's waiting in the car when they
go to that kid's house you know and
harass them uh i was i was really
lobbying to try and like to go i was
like to joel should i should i get out
of the car and no no you just stay in
the car i'm like damn it i want to be in
there and
um
uh but i love making that film i and i
remember john taturo
and i uh who i met i met john for the
first time on board barton fink
so that's how we became oh my god that's
right you guys go back and then we both
ended up living in uh brooklyn and we
both have kids the same age so we would
go bowling at melody lanes in uh
brooklyn and yeah melody lanes fan
and uh
so it was great and they you know and
they got us like you know some experts
to teach us and again i don't think i've
bowled since but at the time i i became
a pretty good
bowler but again they like rehearsed
and um you know it was it was
their writing is just so much fun to do
you know because there's a rhythm to to
it
and uh yeah and i just loved how much i
annoyed uh john goodman's character and
when i read the script though it was
kind of
i you know i it took me a while to to
like to like to cat you know donnie i'm
like i don't know if i want to play this
guy he's just like gets [ __ ] on the
whole movie
you know and then at the end
when you know when they have the fight
with the with the nihilists
and donnie is down you know even before
they have the fight donnie's scared
and you know and goodman's characters
it's all right gunny sorry and i'm like
oh he loves donny you know and then when
donnie's dying it's like
man down you know it's like it's so
sweet and then of course the ashes
that's my favorite scene that i'm in you
know people say
the kong brothers films they usually say
i love you in the wood chipper scene you
know i'm like thanks thank you
and then the other one with the ashes
yeah um had you i'm trying to remember
and i've seen the movie a zillion times
but you don't cross over with goody in
barton fink do you
you don't know what happens to him you
just but i mean you guys didn't have
scenes we don't know we didn't have a uh
we didn't have any scenes so was that
the first time then that you worked with
good i didn't think that was well i you
know saw john around the time of barton
fink and i said to him i said you
remember we we did the equalizer
together
and i loved him and so we you know i
mean we became fast friends yeah um all
right the other movie that came out in
1998 again like well for her before we
go on did you guys know when you were
making big lebowski that it would be no
no no i mean this was their follow-up to
fargo yes right yeah they won academy
awards for fargo and then they come out
with this really weird movie [ __ ]
stoner movie man yeah it is yeah and it
took like
at least five years or more
like after a while i knew who the the
lebowski fans were like these like
college like it looked like these like
just post college like out of college a
few years guys would come up to me and
go
hey man and i would go big lebowski yeah
how'd you know
because they watch it so many times and
so and then as the years go by it's just
become like bigger and bigger it is it's
for me it was a way homer i went to see
it while we were making dogma in 1998 in
pittsburgh and so i went to see and this
is gonna sound so name droppy but just
this is what i went to see it with
me scott mosher my producer ben affleck
matt damon and chris rock
so
ben affleck matt damon i guess we're
just won the oscar
so like they were riding high and stuff
chris rock couldn't have been bigger
than he was at that point and we were
all massive fargo fans so we were like
[ __ ] hey man the lebowski
and when the movie ended
like i can't i'm sure he's come to love
it i i did come to love it my second
viewing i was like oh i don't know what
i didn't see
but the very first viewing we were all
gobsmacked that it wasn't [ __ ] fargo
and i will never forget man i'm not
trying to throw him under the bus it's
very it's just it was so funny to me
chris rock gets up in the middle of the
movie theater as soon as the credits
rolls and he goes
[ __ ]
and the whole [ __ ] crowd turns around
he's like that sounds like chris rock
and it was chris rock
and then we had to get out of the
[ __ ] theater fast
what is chris rock on now
targo holy [ __ ]
it would have been weirder if he was on
the big lebowski that's true yeah my
joke totally that was
if he had just fargo that would have
worked can you edit any of this
live but somebody donate for that go to
the link in the bio in the description
and donate uh friends of firefighters
folks that's who we're here for tonight
uh
speaking of heroes
you played one named rockhound and
armageddon you saved our world that's
right because
you knew how to drill
don't forget
ben affleck on the commentary track i
mean it's very funny but he would say it
in real life too before the commentary
track he's like you know the [ __ ]
world's end and there's an asteroid
coming our way do we send astronauts no
send oil drillers
he's like and that pretty much sums up a
michael bay film what do you remember
about shooting the michael b you know i
almost
didn't do that film because before that
film i was filming stanley tucci's movie
the imposters yeah and the dates were
conflicting
and
um i remember at the time i was like a
little upset you know because
i felt like
wait a minute you're not taking into
account that i'm doing stanley's movie
first you know and i'm doing stanley's
movie
that's a big studio movie disney movie
they don't give a [ __ ] i didn't yeah and
but somehow the dates worked out and i
got to do both both films so that was
amazing that i was even in it and um
yeah it was like it was culture shock
going from like the imposters to
imposters you know this like tight-knit
group and we're shooting in like one
location but basically and then to go on
the set of a michael bay film
but
well i what i love that michael and
jerry ruckheimer what they do is they
you know they they hire good actors i
mean you know they it's like i love the
actors that uh that i was working with
and you know that was on like on on
same thing
and so to do like
an action commercial film
and
you know he's surrounded by like real
actors yeah so and so you really had to
bring your your best game and and uh
and you know michael bay is kind of like
an independent filmmaker with just every
tool
in the toolbox and every toy that he
could play with but he really likes to
sort of
you know like make things up as he goes
along and he likes us to improvise
and um his energy is just you know it's
like
it's he is like his movies you know like
like he is he is he is that guy
expensive yes
somebody told me recently they were
working on something he was working on
and i guess it was a transformers thing
because they he was like
they're outside in some major city
and he's like get everyone out of the
way i have to envision the transformers
so he wanted everyone away so he could
imagine the big giant robots i was like
man that's a gus guy spoiled
um
uh that's chapter nine give it up for
chapter nine kids
three chapters left and chapter 10 takes
us to a personal favor of mine uh not
just because i love the movie but also
because it reminds me of my kid when she
was a kid monsters inc you played
randall boggs man
you went pixar what was that like
i love that you know um
the hardest thing about and i've done a
lot of uh voice-over work you know since
then the hardest thing about it is that
you're alone in the you know in the
studio you know and
and you're not reading with the people
yeah
so on uh monsters inc they did let
um billy crystal and john goodman do
their i think they did a lot of their
stuff together because so much of it is
you know interplay yeah
but me i just came in and i would you
know you know you do do your lines and
then they animate and they bring some
stuff to you and then you you you revise
it
but there was one part
so randall has an assistant in the film
and i don't remember the character's
name but it's voiced by frank oz
so those of you who know frank oz is
like you know like the king of voiceover
and
he's direct brilliant director he had
just he was telling me stories about
directing marlon brando
and you know robert de niro and he's
telling me these stories and then we go
into the studio and he'd be like trying
to find a voice going
it's all hard for him to find original
voice you know he was like trying to go
ah sorry that was fozzie bear sorry let
me try again i need you know
and then we and then they had us
improvise
big scene
where i'm yelling at him and that was so
surreal i'm like i can't believe i'm
here yelling at frank oz like yeah
essentially yelling at yoda
um what a weird job that puts you in a
room with a cat that legendary as well
yeah um what's uh what is the process on
that do you go in once record it and
then two years later you see the movie
or do you have to go oh no you keep
going in you keep going in it's at least
like five or six times and is that
because like they break the script down
or they really well first they need your
voice you know then they then they then
they start to animate and then as things
change then you're just constantly
revising to what now they know what it's
going to look like and
how fast you should say this line or or
they rewrite something and you have to
just redo a scene and so it's yet
another
movie with john goodman which you didn't
get to work with john goodman true yes
yes
um
that's chapter 10 give it up for chapter
10 kids
[Applause]
ernie let's get a quick tally before we
go on to uh 11 and 12. castle smart
castle keeper
uh ernie o'donnell coming here with a
microphone yes
what do you got
with the audience donations
and michael w at two thousand online two
thousand bucks from michael w give it up
for michael w in his two thousand bucks
we have uh we're creeping up on 25 000.
well done kids very close very close
looking good thank you very much
and don't forget man uh you know that's
live but this thing will live online and
people can donate long after this event
is over of course we'd appreciate that
uh the link is in the description below
kids uh give to the friends of
firefighters fund uh help us rescue
those who rescue us uh okay chapter 11
takes us to the sopranos
obviously a close personal fave of of me
and most of the locals of course uh but
before we talk about you playing tony
blandetto you've been on the set
as a director prior to that yeah i had
directed uh at least
two episodes by then the first one being
the pine barrens one of the greatest
[ __ ] episodes not only one of the
not only one of the greatest episodes of
the sopranos ever one of the greatest
hours of television particularly if
you're from new jersey of all time
well that's terry winter wrote the
script david chase of course he had a
hand in every script that was written
and between the two of them it's just
you know this was just an amazing
and tim ben patton who was who is a
director on the show and he ended up
doing a lot of uh most of boardwalk
empire he came up with the story and it
was supposed to be like a bottle episode
like these are episodes that are just
supposed to stand alone
and not cost very much you know and um
that's true the bottle episode is meant
to be inexpensive yeah and so he came up
well how about this idea where you know
they get lost in the woods and it just
like ballooned into this like
almost like this epic
they used to shoot their their episodes
in like nine ten days if they went 11
that we didn't we had to go 14 days it
became that big of an episode
um
but i think it was worth it i think you
know did you get you nominated or did
you win i got didn't win but i was
nominated for a dja award yeah for
directing yeah i've never gotten one of
those so well [ __ ] done
after um
the uh but the so you direct firm a
bunch and do they tell you at that point
one day you're gonna act for us no no um
for some reason like david chase didn't
think that i would actually like do the
show you know like and i i mean i you
know at that time i don't think they had
anything for me but then when they came
up with these four characters who were
getting out of prison and you know
coming back into the family
um
yeah i get you know sheila jaffe
uh and george anne walken who were the
casting directors they cast in the soup
alex rockwell's oh my god that's how i
knew them right and then
they cast trees lounge the first uh film
that i do
you directed yeah david chase
was a a fan of trees lounge and hired
sheila and georgian
and then i think it was sheila you know
that said to david
what about steve and he's like yeah he
well you think he'd do it well let's ask
him you know and i was like yes i'll do
it of course i love the show and it was
like another opportunity to get my guns
out and pump up my arms
like the jock i am at heart and then
they made me wear that like oversized
jacket come on i want to show my arms um
but i loved it but my first day of
working i was so scared because it's bad
it was like
my nerves were afraid enough just
directing these people after watching
because i didn't direct until late into
the third season so it was like you
watch the show and i was such a fan
and then to step into this world that
you know so well and love it's
surreal and it's very intimidating what
was gandolfini like
he was a sweetheart but he can't help
but be intimidating he can't help you
know like if he looks at you you know
you just kind of
voluntarily shake and he's like hey how
are you still i'm good i'm good you're
right
all right okay um
um but just yeah he was just so damn
good at that character
that uh it was hard not to see him that
way in
real life and he was you know he
he was the sweetest guy he was very
generous he definitely had
you know his issues it was not easy for
him to play that part you know he
he
took it to heart
and um and he had to go to some really
dark places
and um
uh and i think it had a toll on on
on him
uh because it was you know there were
things that he was asked to do that i
think was
i could you know you could see him
resisting resisting resisting
and then when he did it he [ __ ] gave
it his all and it was like chilling you
know but he had to go to a very dark
place to achieve that um
what um
when they bring you on to something like
that now they know you from working with
you as a director and whatnot but did
they tell you
in the beginning
like you're probably gonna get [ __ ]
whacked well everybody knows that going
in right
but they hired me for two seasons yeah
so i thought okay they hired me for two
seasons regular
and it was towards the end you know of
the fifth season as we were shooting it
you know the joke on set was you don't
you don't ever want to get a phone call
from david chase
you know that means
you're dead
and of course i got the phone call like
from david like my voicemail hey steve
can you give me a call and i'm like damn
it
i go but
ah well let's just maybe it's something
else i call him back
he says uh
you're free for lunch tomorrow i'm like
yeah sure now i gotta wait a whole night
and then i like
and that night i'm like you know i
shouldn't be so negative maybe he wants
to talk to me about a whole like a
different project you know i'm on for
two seasons
first thing i you know i go meet him for
lunch
i'm sorry there's just no way out of it
we got to kill you
all right let's have lunch
[Laughter]
um
but you know it's it was understandable
that this character like kind of yeah it
just he just had he just had to go
um and i and i really was crushed i mean
i i sort of left you know practically
and i let david see it but i was like
practicing practically in tears like
because i loved it so much i was like oh
damn it how and this is coming from a
guy who's like at this point in his
career
played hundreds hundreds of roles and
still found like a home do you think
it's because
it was episodic like you do a lot of
movies where it's just like you got a
month to live in these skins and then
dump it and this was first kind of like
i had done a lot of tv you know stuff
before that but just like these guest
starring stuff and so i had
never played a recurring role before
and um so yeah of course you get you
just get close to everybody and you get
close to the character and
you know and i wanted to see him i felt
bad you know i'm like
succeed it was so sad when he was
heartbroken when he started beating up
the dude and [ __ ] you're like oh you're
so close i know yeah um all right give
it up for uh 11 chapter 11.
that's chapter 12 our final chapter
ladies and gentlemen brings us to a
boardwalk empire he played thompson
a return to working with mr martin
scorsese how did this come about well
because it was terry winter right so he
was the the the writer the show runner
on um
boardwalk and he you know he brought it
from two
land right he yes i'm sorry so terry
winters was you know wrote the pine
barrens and you know
so many other great scripts on that show
and so when he was doing boardwalk
empire
um
yeah they
i don't know how they got scorsese to do
the pilot but that was like you know uh
i mean i say i don't know how because it
was a [ __ ] great script that's that
and um
so they had marty they had you know
terry
and terry still says he says i don't
know who thought of it first me or marty
but we both agreed that it should be you
and i'm sure they there was a list
of people
and i know that hbo was kind of like
really that's yeah
who else
steve you know
and i always tell the story but like
when terry
called me to tell me that i had the part
i was i was trying to transition into
directing i was i was directing an
episode of nurse jackie and i was on a i
was in this you know we were scouting
i'm on the scout van and i'm like
you know
not that i thought that i was going to
give up acting but i just thought maybe
i'm getting to an age where
the roles are kind of the same and maybe
i should just this makes more sense
you've got so much experience on
everybody else's set you know you
aggregated into your own style i've been
to the best film school in history right
no doubt
think about it yeah dude is set behind
the greatest in terms of people who make
films so yeah it that's the reason you
would direct so i thought all right i'll
you know and then terry calls me and he
says that he's offering me the role and
i still couldn't hear it i said thank
you terry thank you look i know you're
still looking at other actors you know
and but thank you for even he said steve
did you hear me i said you have the part
you know i it
uh it was just amazing you know i was
just so because i read the pilot and i
was like oh my god i [ __ ] love this
if i don't get it i'm good you know i
didn't even want to think about it like
i would rather not even be in the
running and then lose it you know the
fact that they i was being considered
was just
i hadn't felt that nervous since
i wanted to play uh the cowardly lion in
the wizard of oz in my fourth grade play
i'm serious
like that was the only other time where
i felt like i got to get that part what
do i got to do you know
and when i got it i was like i did it
i'm the lion
um
was it four seasons in the show
um
boardwalk was fire was like four and a
half like the last season was not a full
season but they but they let us finish
it which was which was nice where did
you guys shoot
we shot at the
the only
time we set foot in jersey was in the
opening credits is that it
so we shot at steiner studio they you
know built all the most of the interiors
there like nucky's office
they built a boardwalk set in uh
brooklyn like this outdoor set and then
we shot in every borough
for it you know like every borough rep
you know like we would shoot in the
bronx for
uh
for ireland i can't you know and they
would they would just like make up these
places and
uh prospect park was havana you know at
the picnic house it was like they just
were so ingenious
um but it was it was all in new york and
this is the you got to spend more time
with martin scorsese during
the yeah so that pilot was like
like 30 days to shoot and that was
unheard of you know [ __ ] feature
right there yeah and you know and we
just everybody just loved him you know
like we would always love it if there
was like like a technical thing that
went wrong and we had to wait and then
marty would come and sit at our table
and we would just pepper him with
questions because he loves talking about
you know his films and art and music
he's not precious about it like no no
you could ask him anything and and you
know yeah yeah
my the greatest
time i ever had on a set anywhere
was um
there was do you remember robert altman
did this thing
this show back in the 80s
um about a politician now i'm going to
blank
tanner yeah tanner 1888
and then like 20 years later he did like
this like tv series for ifc
where tanner's daughter played by
cynthia nixon
she's a filmmaker and so they follow her
and he was doing a scene at elaine's and
uh he wanted me and scorsese just to be
extras like in the background sitting
sitting at a table
and the main scene was happening with
cynthia and you know and everybody else
at a big table and it's just marty and
me like
like we hang out together and we go to
elaine
and we sat there and marty just kept
telling me story after story about
brando and de niro i always hear the
brando and deniro stories and they and
and every once in a while robert altman
would come up to us and go
uh try not to be so mediocre on that
take and then he'd like walk away
and then in the middle of the scene we
get up and we meet mario cuomo
who's at another table
and uh and i was so nervous i knocked
over a bottle of wine
and it's in this it's in the scene and a
waiter comes and
they cleaned it up and yeah that was my
favorite day on set i think ever
being squished and and altman did the
i've seen two massive greats did they
mike did they mic you guys even though
your background yeah he was famous for
that would put mics on everybody even if
they were background people yeah that's
[ __ ] nuts man oh my god you have
worked with like
every
every director except me it feels like
at this point and i was supposed to
he offered me a part in uh clerk's three
and i i just directed a movie
here's the difference between you and me
you're impressed success
[ __ ] boatloads of success
we're both in pre-productions for movies
we're about to direct and you were like
the most relaxed guy ever
you could always
you can get to him immediately like when
we're putting together this event and
you were so you know and it's not a real
movie it's a kevin smith movie man
and me i'm like uh okay no i can't do
that day because i think i think why i
have a zoom meeting that day so i can't
uh you were you were then i'm gonna go
to l.a and then when i come back i don't
know if i have time you know you were
treating the job seriously like it was
nice to see a director who's like you
know
giving it the value that me i'm just
like it'll be fine we'll make it up jay
will be there and stuff like that
um
uh that was chapter 12. give it up for
chapter 12. oh you know what
that's not
that's not chapter 12 we're going to
jump back into chapter 12 because uh
tragically last week i believe it was uh
we lost uh michael k williams who of
course played chalky white in the show
and you worked with michael a bunch i
loved michael um
his commitment to any role that he
played
was just phenomenal and it did not come
easy to him
you know he
he i just remember we'd be doing these
scenes and we'd you know rehearse them
and he'd be struggling with the lines
and
he you know wouldn't quite find it and
you'd think
i don't know you know and then
he just methodically would work and work
and work and by the end of it
and you know i'm just like blown away
i'm in a scene with an actor and i'm
kind of like having an out-of-body
experience
watching him and just
and
it's so sad
i
when his character was killed and sorry
for any spoiler alerts but his character
gets killed on boardwalk empire i think
i've cried the hardest i've ever cried
you know
seeing for the character or for the fact
that you're like oh man there he goes it
was
because he and the character to me
became one like chalky died but it was
like michael dying then
and it like destroyed me
um and so when he passed away last week
i had this weird feeling like
why do i feel like i've grieved for him
already and that's what it was it came
from me it was so it was so weird
uh he was just
you know just a phenomenal actor and and
a phenomenal guy and a sweetheart he was
a kind kind sweetheart he came to my
house one day and did a podcast one
morning as a matter of fact and he was
such a sweet guy so good natured and
whatnot absolutely lovely
it was very sad to read that news last
week because not only did we lose a
lovely guy we lost an amazing oh my god
yeah uh a pillar of hbo if you look at
it wire the wire
i loved craft country i love cross
country
i was
you know how we do you you see your
buddy do great work i gotta call him i
gotta send him an email and then it you
just forget the message ah man i never
got a chance to tell him um it is don't
don't carry that cross man you're a no
no he knows anyway but it's just i just
wish i would have talked to him you know
because it had been a few years since
since we hung out that's beautiful uh
that is chapter 12. give it up for
chapter 12 kids
all try uh 12 chapters of a career done
in uh two hours let's stop for a moment
and see uh how we're doing with our
totals uh earn
what do you got for us what are the
friends of firefighters uh looking at
well after adding up all the lovely
donations from the audience and uh on
the internet and the sales from
tonight's tickets yeah we were at thirty
six thousand dollars thirty six thousand
so
close so close to 37.
37's close buddy we'll get there we'll
get there
um very nice thank you ernie uh okay
uh we obviously didn't do every damn
thing you've ever done because you've
done so much uh we touched on you
directing the pine barrens and we
mentioned trees lounge how do you like
directing you talked about how you were
kind of like i'm gonna lean toward this
but and then more acting happened yeah
so that's what happens i like directing
but i don't get to do it that much so
every time i do it it's like
i get that you know i get so anxious
um
and i you know
that's i i feel like if i did it more
then i would sort of you know become
more like you and be more like relaxed
about it and bad at it
it takes a career to be practiced and
bad at your job
um no i i do like the way you do it man
it reminds me like oh [ __ ] i should take
this seriously oh come on come on
i you know i have to say when uh when
clerks came out
it was
do tell steve buscemi
because i remember also reading at the
time you you talked about jarmish and
you talked about stranger than paradise
and i went so this
this is this is what happens here so jim
you know he grew up in cincinnati and
you know came to new york
did his did his he was influenced by by
cassavetes and the new year
and now he makes his film his way
and inspires a kid from new jersey and
you make your film a black and white
film and you make it your way
i made it his way a series of one long
takes i know but you but but yes but
it's your film you made it you made it
your own and i loved that you gave it up
you said yeah you were influenced you
was like okay it inspired you and he did
that
i think i can do that like you saw
because it was such a personal film
to him
i think that's you know like that really
inspired you and
you did it in your first film man you
were like on your way it was it was such
a beautiful it's all downhill after that
steve but yeah
right out the gate it was strong
um
uh let's uh let's uh let's let's
let me ask you this
because you mentioned something about
like you know
art inspires art i did see jarmish's
stuff and that made me go like maybe i
could do this sort of thing
how many people have you met across your
lifetime
who are acting because of you because
you
look like us unlike what the coen
brothers said you don't look funny
looking you look like us you look like
the audience you look normal
um you know most people they put up on
the screen are like impossibly gorgeous
and [ __ ] cut and all that stuff but
you look like a normal person so i can
see i've had a career where people are
like because you're normal and you made
a movie that made me think i could do a
thing or try a thing have you
encountered a lot of that you mean
of actors yeah people who are like i'm
doing this because i saw you do it you
specifically um
i guess i mean i've met a lot of young
i'm sorry i've met a lot of young actors
and it's always nice to hear
you know that that they're that they're
inspired or influenced
um for me the guy was john cassell
you know this was a guy who i first saw
in the godfather and then i see him
in dog day afternoon and it blew me away
because it took me a while to realize
that it was the same guy he's the same
guy al pacino you know you know like
he's the star and he's like oh he's
doing a different role that's so cool
but that guy's really good too
oh he was frederico in the godfrey it
just kind of blew me away and sort of
opened my eyes to a whole
like what what it meant to be a
character actor and that was a huge loss
you know when uh he died i would love to
you know imagine what he would have been
doing you know like
in these all in like all these years but
yeah so that so him like that for me was
like ah
i think i can do that who who'd you do
it for have you ever met somebody who
was like
i saw you do a thing and now i can do
that thing
um
that that i've that i've that you've
inspired yeah oh that i've inspired i
don't know i i don't i don't i don't i
don't know
i got to imagine a guy like you like
here's a beverage if there's a mount
rushmore of american actors like you're
on it so i assume that like most people
would be like oh my god i'm doing this
because of you
there might there might be i don't know
you're embarrassing me now i don't know
cut it out fair enough um let me ask you
this to close up the evening and before
we close up ladies and gentlemen have
you had a good time so far
[Applause]
if if you've enjoyed this amazing walk
down memory lane uh don't forget who
we're doing it for it's the friends of
firefighters if you're watching online
there's a link in the description below
if you're watching long after this event
has taken place five ten years after
this when we're dealing with kova 28. um
don't forget take care of that and then
give to the friends of firefighters uh
folks um
let's close up by asking this you've had
this
massive
not just career but life but we'll stick
to career
um
and you've done so much and it's unfair
to be like you know single out the one
thing but
like you know if
if you have to if there's a [ __ ]
heaven and they're like all right we're
only letting you in
based on what you think your [ __ ]
best performance was oh my god yeah
that's right it's a vicious heaven
it's just like earth it's real judgy and
[ __ ]
what's the one that gets you into heaven
into film heaven i mean i did play god
in the first season of miracle workers
and
i mean that might get me in if he
doesn't watch it if god doesn't watch me
watch and see what i did i'd be like
god you inspired me
maybe he would you know just all right
you're in okay you can't let me out now
i'm in
uh nobody's letting you out man once you
got in you were in for life and stuff uh
it's been amazing
watching your career i've grown up
watching your career uh and not like i
was a boy
i'm i'm 51 how old are you i'm 63. okay
so you got me by like a decade and stuff
but i've i you know in the 80s i got to
see stuff that you were doing that fed
me when i got to the 90s i did my thing
um it's it's amazing to share stage
space
with a guy whose work you've absolutely
adored over the years but it's amazing
not just the work that you've done in
film uh but the work you're doing with
friends of firefighters as nancy
mentioned earlier in the evening you're
you're a firefighter and you were there
on september 11th tomorrow is the 20th
anniversary you know we've had a good
time tonight we've had laughs and
whatnot this may be a bit more sober but
what a what do you remember about the
day
well uh yeah so i used to work in engine
55 in italy in the early 80s for four
years
i wasn't there on september 11th i went
the next day
on the 12th and um
had my
turnout coat and my helmet and just took
the subway to delancey street made my
way to the firehouse
another firefighter was uh
was coming back and he gave me the
update i didn't because i couldn't get
any information and so five members of
engine 55 were missing
and of course died
um and
uh he drove me in and and
um
already it was you know one of the guys
i had worked with faust apostle and so
he was a good friend and
um
and as i was walking around there i
would run into other firefighters that i
knew and they would tell me about other
guys
i found my old company
they let me work with them that day and
then they invited me back the next day
and the next day and i ended up going in
with them for almost a week
and
just you know being on the bucket line
and you know just helping to remove the
rubble
and um
um but it was
you know an experience that i will never
forget
i hope that i never have to experience
it again because of you know the
magnitude of the tragedy that it was
but
the the love and the humanity that i
witnessed
my days there on the pile
uh just was extraordinary you know
uh it was
uh
love in action
somebody told me that the other day and
i went that's exactly what it was
you know in the face of this incredible
evil
um there was so much love
there
uh people wanting to desperately find
survivors
um
you know because they because in the
beginning it's it it was a rescue
mission and it was you know such a it's
so tragic that they
that there were no uh survivors after
the first day
and
just to witness all of those groups
coming together the fire department the
cops transit steel workers construction
sanitation
red cross
um
was just uh
i don't even know how to explain it it
was just i felt good
while i was there
um
sometimes i even felt guilty about how
good i felt because
i you know you could see like this
destruction and you know that there are
thousands of people who have died
but because i was privileged enough to
have access and i was able to do
something
um
it it felt good and it felt good to be
connected with my with my with my old uh
company
and there are a lot of new guys now and
they accepted me in and that was you
know i loved that and now i'm
uh you know friends with with with them
and it wasn't until i stopped going
that i experienced what i think
everybody was experienced like just just
what the [ __ ] happened you know like
this fear and anxiety and anger and
what called you to the pile well just
once a firefighter always yeah when i
heard the numbers of
you know the first number that i heard
of the missing it was like about a
hundred this was like
maybe in the late afternoon on september
11th they were estimating that it was
100 and the you know being 343.
um
it was just you just couldn't imagine it
you know i mean there have been
fatalities before you know on the fire
department you know
you know
i mean if one dies it's like it's huge
when like six die it's like oh my god
you know
this so this was like you just couldn't
imagine the number
and
i
yeah i just wanted i just wanted to be
there
and this is something i say all the time
i wanted to help like every like so many
new yorkers wanted to help
and uh but i'm the one that
got the help i i felt like it didn't me
you know did my heart
so good to just
be there and to witness that and be a
part of that ex part of that experience
that's what got me through it really
give up for steve matt's beautiful
let us check
one last time ladies and gentlemen with
our final tally before we get out of
here for this evening ernie o'donnell
come out and tell us if we've done
any bit better
so in this short time we have reached
your magic number 37 000 bucks we got
over to 37 37
well done kids very on brand very nice
works well thank you all
great stuff guys great stuff awesome the
uh folks have you had a good time
uh if you did it's because we got to sit
here and listen uh to a living legend
man um
i know
the movie says differently
but please
never shut the [ __ ] up donny
everyone give it up for steve buscemi
thank you kevin how about
this guy is amazing he did this for us
last year with soprano's event if like
you saw that he moderated that he raised
a lot of money for friends of
firefighters he was asked he just did it
immediately he became fast friends with
nancy nancy's been doing this you know
since the beginning and i just so i just
want to acknowledge everybody who works
at friends of firefighters the staff the
counselors the volunteers
because it's important to keep this
going you know
for a lot of the firefighters and first
responders 911 never never stopped you
know they're experiencing you know like
i said before the cancers this being the
20th year is a big trigger
a lot of the members are just not even
you know they just can't even deal with
it
so um
mental health is as important as any
other you know health you know we
we and we owe it to them we
we owe it to them to give them support
because they are there for us in a
heartbeat they don't even think twice
about it so
whatever you can do and everything you
have done
we really appreciate it and i appreciate
this guy right here i think he's amazing
thank you
thank you
thank you uh to all the good folks
friends of firefighters thank you to
everybody who donated tonight thank you
to all the future donor donors who are
gonna watch this tomorrow next week a
month from now uh don't be shy that
money spends all the time and is always
very needed for a great cause uh from
smod castle here in leonardo new jersey
uh thank you for being with us here
tonight ladies and gentlemen go give
somebody some love tonight give somebody
a hug goodnight everybody
[Applause]
you